well i'm i'm big into men's right so
that's what the channel's about you're
bringing into men's right as a woman
yeah yeah i think i think that men need
to be advocated for too i think like
there's always women's rights we don't
ever talk about men okay i agree but
like overall
you as a woman
who have clearly historically
systematically been oppressed how can
you then say you advocate for men's
right well because i i don't believe
i've been oppressed i don't i've been
depressed no okay i'll give i'll give
you an example
yeah i don't i don't believe women have
been impressed and this woman tonight
men's hands around my throats i leave a
place a bar down the street
because no
you're too much for me you're too pretty
i i can't deal with you i've been told
that i was going to get because i didn't
want to get home with someone i've been
told i've got date right in my drink
because i don't want to go home with
someone and you're trying to tell me
women haven't been oppressed i don't
know not by and large men men get
assaulted too
i'm saying
and i'm saying can i can i need you to
let me talk okay because if we're gonna
have it we're gonna have like
like for her like yelling at me it's not
really productive so it's like
so i'm saying i'm saying like men get
assaulted and they're not taken
seriously like if a woman gets assaulted
what happened with amber hurt
she came forward people just
automatically believed her and she was
able to accuse a man of things that he
didn't even do and that's a man with
power money and privilege what happens
to the average guy that happens to like
we like we had a whole movement called
believe yeah so it's like if that
happened to a rich powerful man what
does that mean for the average guy
and like that doesn't happen to women
like women automatically are believed
where men aren't and like it happens
from a history like women are in a place
of like lower power so how could we say
that we're at a place of lower power
when we never had to fight in wars men
were the ones that were forced to go out
and fight and protect women where women
women didn't even have the option to go
and fight because they were seen as too
weak women didn't actually so you might
not know this the women didn't actually
want the right to vote because it came
with being drafted so if you if you
surveyed women a hundred years ago do
you want the right to vote yes or no
most said no because they had to be
drafted so okay i didn't they didn't
want to do that i don't know the facts
behind that but i just don't see how
that could possibly be true if the
suffragette you like movement like how
is that suffrage it was actually started
in um new york and it was started by men
it wasn't started by women okay really
yeah it was in seneca falls new york um
i can't remember the exact year off the
top of my head but yeah it wasn't
started by it was um a group of 300
people and the majority were men please
help me okay they're going please
yeah and so i i just think men like
they're they're not believe they're not
taken seriously when they have claims of
assault and that's a real problem
and so even even in this conversation
when i say like that i think men have a
problem like it's always women have to
come forward and say well what about our
problems and we're talking about that
the point you're coming across have like
men don't have the the voice to be
saying oh i've been assaulted whatever i
see that point especially like being a
gay male or whatever like it takes a lot
for someone to come out and be like okay
i've i've been solid like walking down
the street or whatever but i just think
it's kind of like rude for your argument
to be then that women don't have
oppression or whatever like that no i i
just don't think we have in 2022 you
have so much privilege as a young pretty
girl in my
workplace the work of like hierarchy
it's like 75 mail to women so do you
know do you know why that is why because
men pick harder jobs men work more hours
no no if you look at so and i'm just
saying like if you just google like
google what percent of what percent of
women are plumbers what percent so
plumbing electrician garbage okay i
understand that but that's different
that society telling men that they
should become plumbers that's not women
not becoming plumbers or getting a hard
working job so i i used to think that
too right i literally i used to think
that but when you look at countries that
are more so if you look do a list of
countries right and you pick the
countries that are more free and then do
the countries that are the least free
for women and it's pretty easy to like
to pick those you go to the scandinavian
countries there's more free if you go to
the south like saudi arabia less free
what the pay gap
gets bigger the more choice women have
which seems to indicate that women pick
jobs that make less money when they're
given more choice okay so i haven't
looked into that so i can't really
comment on that no it's okay i don't
expect you to come in knowing everything
yeah but so i just think a lot of times
the narrative is like that women are
oppressed and i genuinely think that a
lot of men have it harder than us and we
don't advocate for them like like for
example if if i get married and i get a
divorce um who's the one collecting
child support and in the us there are
men that commit suicide over going into
so much debt over child support
like like there are women stealing
condoms from the nba trying to get
pregnant like and so it's just like
these are men's issues that i think are
important i feel like it's very
different like we're in the uk you can't
really i don't think in terms of looking
at america's statistics it shouldn't
really be applied to the uk it's very
it's a it's very different climate the
uk the uk has similar problems they also
have child support like i've interviewed
men on the channel that come forward and
say like yeah that girl tried to get
like like she told me she was on birth
control to try to get pregnant off that
is definitely an issue and like i've
heard of that before but that is very
based on the individual i don't know i
just think as a woman are you saying
you're not a feminist no i wouldn't call
myself a feminist because i just i think
in 2022 what am i fighting for we have
all the rights okay that's crazy
oh you know what what right do i not
have so do you do you go to nightclubs
no i don't drink there you go so i think
that is mainly your issue so you you
don't go to nightclubs you don't put
yourself and i guess it's kind of like
oh just a woman put herself in that
percentage but it's not if you're going
on a night out you're having fun that's
you deciding i'm going to go out with my
friends and then a man a man is taking
advantage of you you shouldn't then be
blamed for oh i wore a short dress like
i was going having fun like before you
were saying if a girl wears red lipstick
like she's asking for it no i didn't say
that we have the recording okay so so no
i'm not knowing yeah so i didn't say she
along the lines no no i wasn't saying
she's asking for it i'm saying that's
what it indicates sexual arousal i'm
saying so i think that's weird because
in my head as a student who studies
fashion
red lipstick as seen as like fashionable
it's like a catwalk like red lipstick is
a very prominent thing in fashion it's
not oh i'm i'm sexually active like i
want people to have sex with me it might
not be intentional but like there's
reasons that like like that we put the
makeup on the way we do it like like
like mascara mascara indicates bigger
eyes like men are attracted to bigger
eyes
see like to me you want to come in i
just think that's down to you like if
you're putting mascara on to have bigger
eyes
and you're thinking i'm gonna have
bigger eyes to attract a man and that's
down to you do you know what's
interesting when i do these interviews
like it's not it's not the men who are
rude to me it's always the women and
it's like i almost got like a girl was
trying to attack me like honestly like
i'm saying like genuinely i'm more
afraid of getting attacked by women than
i am by men i just think that's because
you're not showing yourself as wanting
like for a woman i just think that's
because you're not advocating for women
to have like
but it shouldn't be like i am allowed to
have a different opinion than a woman so
so like i think as women if you're
really a feminist you should support
women that have different opinions than
you i think and so i'm saying like when
i when i when i can i just finished like
yeah so like when i'm doing these street
interviews it's very frustrating because
the women that say they're advocating
for me are the same ones trying to throw
hands because
the people that are advocating for you
you're completely backfiring to them and
saying you're not advocating for women
at all no i'm saying they're not
advocating for me because i should be
like it's a conversation for yourself
you're saying you're not a feminist so
you don't want equal rights you just
want to say no no that's not what i said
i'm saying we have you i'm saying i'm
not feminist sorry i'm not a feminist
because we have all the rights we
so i'm asking what law or policy do we
need in 2022 i just think it should be
easy because like we're so oppressed so
what's what's one okay well i don't know
oppressed intensive laws but i know
oppressed in terms of society you said
you don't go clubbing so my friends they
go clubbing and they get sexually abused
almost people grab them people touch
them and it's inappropriate
you know men are more likely to be
victims of a violent crime you're not
entitled to safety